ينضم الينا هنا في هذه النافذه وزير
خارجيه السونيا
اهلا وسهلا بك
سيد الوزير
تابعنا الكلمات كلمه
ايمانويل ماكرون الان كلمه المستشاره
الملك كانت حاضره كان حذرا في موضوع
التسييح الكامل لاوكرانيا يزعجكم هذا
الامر انتم
اعتقد ان غساله الرئيس
الصمود وثبات بان اوكرانيا تحتاج الى
المزيد من الدعم الدولي وخاصه في جانب
السلاح وان اوكرانيا بامكانها ان تنتصر في
الحرب في هذا العام ربما القاده
الاوروبيون واستجابتهم كانت تتسم بالحذر
من حيث انهم مستعدون لدعم اوكرانيا
وايا كان الوقت وحجم المساعده لكن
اطار مؤتمر
هنا المؤتمر الامني هنا في برلين يتاثر
باطار الحرب الروسيه على اوكرانيا وعلى
الدول الاوروبيه ان تستمر في العسل روسيا
وفي تزويد اوكرانيا بالمزيد من السلاح
حفاظا على السلام في اوروبا
نعم لكن انتم سيدي الوزير في استونيا انتم
في قلبي المواجهه انتم طبعا دول البلطيق
الليتوانيا وايضا
كان معنا اليوم ايضا رئيس لاتفيا في نافذه
سابقه انتم ثلاث هذه الدول الثلاث يعني في
الجبهه المعاديه لروسيا
والناطق باسم الكرملين
كان قد حذر منذ قال ان دول البلطيق
وبولندا على استعداد للقيام باي شيء من
اجل التصعيد مع روسيا تحسبون حسابا لذلك
بهذه العواقب
تماما نحسب لذلك حساباته لاننا نحن على
درايه كامله بانه لو ان نتيجه هذه الحرب
تم تاويلها على اساس انها النصر لروسيا
هذا يعني اننا سنواجه خطرا وجوديا وان
حدود اوروبا يمكن ان تتغير بقوه السلاح
والدبابه ومن ثم فان النتيجه يجب ان تكون
على اساس معاقبه المعتدي وايضا ان يتحمل
المعتدي تبعاتي القانونيه لاعماله وان كل
اراضي اوكرانيا يجب ان تتحرر
استونيا ساهمت باكثر من 1% من اجمالين
ناتجه المحلي دعما لاوكرانيا وندعو جميع
حلف الناتو ان يحذوا حظنا في ذلك
طيب تدعو حلف الناتو ولكن طبعا انتم اعضاء
في حلف النيتو لكن هل تتوقع انه لو حدث
لاستونيا على خط المواجهه لو حدث لها
عدوان من طرف روسيا يتدخل نيته لحمايتكم
هل وجودكم يطمئنكم الى هذا الحد
[موسيقى]
نعم تماما نتوقع ذلك فان هناك قوات
امريكيه موجوده في سوريا بقوات بريطانيه
في استراليا وايضا قوات للحلفاء موجوده في
بلدان البلطيق الاخرى اذا رسالتنا واضحه
انه ليس هناك اي اسباب عاطفيه تبعدنا تبعد
لكن هي قدرات نيتو العسكريه هي التي تبعد
الخطر روسيا عنا طبعا نحن نتطلع قدما الى
ان تصبح اوكرانيا هي الاخرى عفوا في حلف
النيتو
شكرا جزيلا لك وزير خارجيه استونيا اورما
شكرا جزيلا لك